hey have you heard the one about the
congressman being raped it's a good one
oh you must not be watching Bill Maher
Bill Maher is not a man he's simply a
coward it's not because they have
breasts it's because they are boobs and
the leader of a strange family of inbred
weirdos straight out of The Hills Have
Eyes now I'm not just saying Bill
Maher's not a man because he's never had
to provide for a family I'm not saying
he's not a man because he's never had
the guts to marry a woman and instead
decides to bed porn stars in order to
fill the love void that daddy left I'm
not even saying it because he could do
some freaking push-ups
Bill Maher is not a man because he's
never met an easy target that he didn't
like people like him only say things
from the safety of their stages
surrounded by their entourage is where
you know what would happen if they said
this to someone in real life you know
your uh your wife there's really an
inbred moral but I'd sure love to wait
what'd you say what I said gypsy Maher
wouldn't last four seconds with any
moderately athletic human being on the
planet Sarah Palin included but from the
comfort of his show Bill Maher and his
guests are the very definition of
bully's picking on a serve those Sarah
Palin and Michele Bachmann all one of
the guys of political incorrectness
people out there like Bill Maher you
don't even try to take any risks as a
man how does that feel being politically
incorrect would be pointing out that
this administration is the single
biggest failure in modern American
history that Barack Obama is a huge
disappointment to the African American
community not only as their first
president but that as a black guy Sarah
Palin would absolutely just him on the
basketball court a man who has driven us
off a cliff of debt who has flipped the
birds to our greatest allies whose
single biggest accomplishment in life
would be that during his formative years
he could have snorted Elton John under
the table
a man
looks like a manly or less attractive
photo negative of Sigourney Weaver was
shocked that's how you be politically
incorrect tell me
let's roll another clip with Marv and
one of his guests I don't want to be
crass but I just hope that marcus
bachmann takes all that you know that
rage that comes from repression and
denial and brings it into the bedroom
with her and oh here comes the
introspective social commentary from the
aging hipster musketeer dropout
Christians are sexually repressed haha
there's a new one that despite what the
sitcoms try and sell you married people
have more sex a lot more sex fad couples
who wait for sex until they're married
have longer more fulfilling sex lives
try remembering that the next time you
toss on Animal Collective as you
sobbingly fondle yourself in the dark
but folks the genius went on to deliver
this Jim I hope you keep her angrily
because because that's how I would and I
thought about it
hey Count of Monte Cristo I've got a
better idea since you left us believe in
hate speech how about we jail you for it
and allow them to angrily have their way
with you there he'll be doling out
mustache rides whether you want to or
not
that's how you be politically incorrect
hope you like it and I hope you've
learned something today